across the country lots of opinions
about a change to the mandatory mask
rule I think uh loosening up the
restrictions on masks
making them voluntary is reasonable I'm
happy I can honestly say that I think
that with the recirculation that they
have on the airplanes
it's a great system I'm not concerned it
was difficult to wear mask all the time
especially when I had when I came here I
was with kids so it was difficult for
them mandatory Mass use in airports on
planes and on trains is optional as of
Saturday many plan to keep the mask the
thing that's not optional is how close
you are to the person you're sitting
beside I'm vaccinated and I will still
wear a mask on the plane my husband is
recovering from cancer and I think
there's a lot of people that are have
immune system issues experts say the
risk of catching covet during a flight
is low the plane ride itself yes while
there can be covered transmission on
that plane it's way lower than what
people might think because of the uh
very impressive ventilation uh
engineering that they have on flights it
would be crowds elsewhere during the
trip at the luggage carousel for
instance that may still merit Mass use
the mask rule is one of many changes
about to happen no more mandatory use of
the arrive can app to submit Public
Health info proof of vaccination no
longer required no more testing on
arrival no more health checks that said
Canadian citizens will still need to
show proof of vaccination to get into
the United States the U.S is not
changing its rules at this time but
Canadian authorities believe current
data on the spread of the virus was
enough to support a change for Canada as
the pandemic evolves so do our Public
Health measures and just to underline
all these rule changes do not take
effect immediately vaccine requirements
mask requirements they remain in effect
all week
they end on Saturday Donna David Aiken
at ottawa's airport thank you